originaire d'asie la marjolaine a été
introduite à la réunion par les engagés
indiens utilisé lors des cérémonies
religieuses et aussi dans la cuisine
comme condiment cette herbe aromatique
et reconnaissable par ses feuilles
ovales et par ces toutes petites fleurs
de couleur rose pâle marie jolène encore
lily marie jolène un petit isard nossik
nous trous dans les cours des personnes
qui connaît l'utilisation de marjolaine
c'est sûr que avant l'avait plus de
marjolaine dans les eaux dans les cours
aujourd'hui des mines abandonnées un
petit peu ça mais celle qui plante qui
pousse facilement un très beau parfum et
qui est très utile quand on est agitée
et qu'on a les enfants agités
c'est une petite plante que les utilisez
toujours utilisé pour calmer et aussi
pour le somail petit peu de marjolaine
ne soit avant de dormir une petite
incision de marjolaine vraiment il
fallait bien y apporte le calme et la
paix zibi lité pour la nuit tu as une
bonne nuit de sommeil et les enfants
agités milieu et même qu'on peut faire
les bains avec un petit peu de
marjolaine et d'autres petites plantes
un petit peu de racines de sensitive un
petit peu de tomber c'est à ces petites
plantes que les vraiment apprécié dans
les tisanes qu'allemande sommeil
marijuana
ça pousse facilement du coin ou c'est
que c'est assez arrosée et ça peut être
aussi résistantes aux sécheresses et ça
tient le coup ça repousse tous les
anciens tarifs belle petite fleur à
prendre la plante quand elle est fleuri
comme ça là encore meilleur quand il est
fleuri comme ça pour utilisation
personnellement c'est tout un plan cul
utilisé une fois que la plante est bien
mûre bien bien adultes
c'est sûr que lorsqu'elle est fleuri
quand la plante les fleury l'e mail et
mieux les meilleurs mais c'est tout à
plantes les petites failli le type
coupe tout et je me fais des
préparations avec toute la plante là les
petits tiges les feuilles qu'hitler est
bien séché d'abord surtout quand les
bien humide comme ça pour un petit je
venais de pluie donc bien sécher un
endroit sec paquet insectes aussi pose
dessus est ensuite utilisée il fois bien
coupé bien séché bien préparé voilà la
marjolaine
quand je vois le manipule facilement il
pousse facilement dans l'est où comme
dans les bars ça pourrait être aussi
dans l'avenir des recherches de plantes
pour nous fournir des huiles
essentielles c'est comme ci comme ça une
façon enfin n'importe quand même pas mal
lu essentiel marjolaine peut être une
petite plante qui peut être distillées
ici et produire cette huile essentielle
donc c'est vrai que l'huile essentielle
comme toutes les huiles essentielles à
utiliser avec parcimonie et à faire
attention
les femmes enceintes les personnes qui
ont des problèmes de peau ça peut brûler
des problèmes de peau ne pas utiliser
des huiles essentielles fait la peau
comme ça directement ça peut brûler
titah fusion diana et d'anis nous a bien
mangé rae ne va pas ça juste après pour
bien digérer voilà le petit isard n'est
pas née alice à nice bien mélanger la
peut rajouter un petit peu de marjolaine
dedans y fera pas de mal voilà les à 5,6
personne n'avait la dose ou cinq six
personnes il va mettre ça dans un petit
récipient l'un pour verser là dessus de
l'eau que la bouillie de sawtche au
dessus bon on va laisser ça voilà la
plante
l'eau commence à changer de couleur la
voix bien et ça commence à être parfumée
aussi on sent la bonne tisane
ça c'est ma ruelle un pouce le petit pot
que va être déposée là pour reprendre
des boutures après un petit bouquet de
marjolaine ça c'est une petite boutique
de marennes ville fait enfin petit coeur
de marché
on met ça dans un petit pot l'a vite
fait on a des plans de marc genêt
beaucoup pas mettre en pots en terre un
petit pin marjolaine là là on fait ça
comme ça la marge elle n'est pas
difficile pour pousser voilà un petit
peu de marge hélène bien arrosée à
partir